what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and spiderman no way
home is dominating the box office right
now it's about to be in the top 20
biggest movies of all time and that's
during a pandemic you have to wonder if
we weren't in a pandemic could spiderman
noway home already have been in the top
20 top 10 maybe even the biggest movie
of all time already unfortunately we'll
never know but it's doing fantastic and
spoiler warning i will be talking about
spider-man no way home spoilers in this
video because we're going to be talking
about toby maguire and andrew garfield's
spider-man we have some more talk today
from people over at marvel studios that
supports the fact that toby and andrew
could be getting some major screen time
in some upcoming marvel projects in fact
they could even go on to be in some
projects together again today we have
some news from the writers of spider-man
knowie home chris mckenna and eric
sommers talking about an alternate
spider-man knowing home post credit
scene involving toby mcguire and andrew
garfield one that we didn't get to see
but almost did and they also go on to
talk about some ideas and pitches
they've had for toby maguire and andrew
garfield spider-man down the road which
is great news this means that marvel
studios is considering keeping them
around and not just using them for this
one-time cameo for both of them in
spider-man noway home so let's dive into
what the writers had to say in a recent
interview about andrew garfield and toby
maguire and of course if you love marvel
and want to stay up to date on the mcu
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so in an
interview with variety spider-man no way
home writers chris mckenna and eric
summers revealed that there were other
plans for a different post-credit scene
involving toby mcguire and andrew
garfield's lives in their own universes
now in spider-man know we home we heard
a tiny bit about what happened to andrew
garfield and his universe after the
amazing spider-man 2 and tobin maguire
in his universe after spider-man 3. we
heard a little bit more about andrew's
life than toby's andrew said that at one
point he got bitter he stopped holding
his punches he got angry and it sounds
like he got pretty violent meanwhile
toby maguire spider-man revealed that
him and mj made it work they're still
together and he's still spider-man and
he's still trying to be better like he
told doc ock and that's kind of all we
got and i know a lot of people really
wanted to maybe see a glimpse into their
lives what has happened in their
universes after their last movies well
there's some good news we still might
get that down the road and we almost got
that in a post-credits scene the writers
revealed that there were at one point in
time plans to continue toby mcguire's
and andrew garfield story in the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home now they say continue the story so
i'm assuming what they were going to
show us is toby going back to his
universe and andrew going back to his
and showing us what happened during that
time so this probably wasn't going to be
a look into the past and what has
happened since their last movies but
showing them when they got back to their
universes almost giving us a glimpse of
what could be coming for them as far as
story-wise so for toby maguire
spider-man what we probably would have
seen is him going back to mj and perhaps
maybe even a daughter or some kids we
would have gotten a little glimpse of
what toby maguire spider-man had been up
to how he's living does he live in a big
house does he still live in a small
apartment is there a new villain that
could possibly be coming could dr
strange maybe have showed up and said
that he needs his help for multiverse of
madness who knows unfortunately we were
kind of robbed of this scene i actually
would have personally really liked this
post-credits scene more than the venom
post-credits scene or i could have even
lived without the multiverse of madness
teaser trailer because we ended up
getting it like two weeks later after
the movie released and then we have
andrew garfield spider-man and we don't
really know anything about what he could
have possibly been up to now we know
that at one point in time mj was
supposed to come into the scene she was
even going to be played by shailene
woody and they actually shot some scenes
that never made it into any cut but he
did mention to toby during the movie
that he didn't have a woman he didn't
have any time but perhaps this
conversation with toby could have
changed his mind about things because
toby told him not to give up he told him
that it was hard for him but they made
it work then not to mention he saw how
happy tom holland's peter parker and
zendaya were together and saw how much
they cared for each other so this
combined with what toby said could have
sparked a little bit of romantic
interest back into his mind about mj so
perhaps we could have seen him go back
to his universe and perhaps we could
have seen him get a different
perspective on life and spider-man he
said he got bitter and stopped holding
his punches well perhaps he won't be so
bitter anymore and perhaps he'll go take
a shot at mj perhaps he decided that it
is finally time to move on from gwen
because he had his redeeming moment he
caught mj he saved her life he redeemed
himself so perhaps he can finally move
on and based off what the writers
further said it sounds like we could
have a chance to actually see that
happen since spider-man no way home's
release insiders like my time to shine
hello and daniel rpk have stated that
toby maguire and andrew garfield could
be returning and that they actually do
have plans for them to return in
multiple different projects and a big
rumor right now is the amazing
spider-man 3 could happen of course it's
not confirmed yet but given andrew's
performance in spider-man now a home i
think a ton of people really want this
to happen now in fact i hear there's a
petition going around now to make the
movie happen but here's what the writers
had to say when teasing ideas that the
team discussed in regards to this movie
spider-man noway home chris mckenna
admitted that he would love to see their
stories continue saying i would hope so
i would love to see more of their
journey we even talked about oh we could
do a post credit tag with this one we
could do a tag with that one basically
stating that they talked about a lot of
ideas of what they could do with toby
maguire and andrew garfield eric sommers
even joked around that they had this
idea of the two of them teaming up in
some type of tv show the two of them
going around in a van solving mysteries
together kind of like scooby doo he said
can we do a tv show with the two of them
traveling around in a van solving
mysteries this was an actual idea talked
about at marvel studios and sony and
mckenna added like no you weren't
supposed to say that we're doing a toby
and andrew in a van going from town to
town of course he was joking about him
not being able to say that but the
biggest thing to take away here is that
ideas for toby and andrew have been
discussed over at the studios now the
two insiders that i mentioned before did
both state that toby is not going to be
getting another solo film but andrew
might and this makes sense toby maguire
is much older now you could tell in the
movie that he was much older but andrew
garfield is still a young guy and has a
lot of life left in him he could easily
do another solo movie or he could even
team up with some other people like
spider-gwen or he could be sony
spider-man in their own universe he
could go on to fight craven the hunter
he could go on to fight eddie brock and
venom there's lots of potential there
and he could even be used in the mcu
that's kind of a really cool thing about
this here is that the universes can kind
of be switched because with the
multiverse anything is possible and toby
has been rumored to be in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness for a
pretty long time now it's not confirmed
yet but according to recent reports
marvel studios is considering bringing
back toby maguire for some other
projects and maybe doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness is one of those
and i'd love to see him in that movie
i'd love to see him really in any other
movie in the mcu i think it would be
really awesome i think they should keep
him around and i think ultimately years
down the road everything kind of leads
to avengers secret wars battle world
where we see all of the variants of all
of our favorite heroes kind of come
together in a way and fight all the bad
variants i think the multiversal war is
going to happen again and i think all of
the good variants are going to have to
get together in order to take down king
dr doom galactus whoever is going to be
responsible for all the bad things
happening they'll have to get together
in order to defeat them and fix
everything but that's just my thought
let me know what you think about all of
this in the comments down below do i
even need to ask if everybody wants to
see toby and andrew again i think
everybody would love that but again let
me know your thoughts i'm personally all
for it and really really really hope it
happens and of course if i hear anything
i'll be sure to let everybody know so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof